my method from the syllabus and the
universe hey did you know that we here
at cinemasins have a podcast I did not
know that it's true
it's called sim cast and we've been
doing it since all the way back in 2015
seriously thought since you're currently
on YouTube being made prefer to listen
to stuff here right goddamn right for
that reason we're debuting the official
sin cast YouTube channel you'll be able
to listen to sober movie analysis this
movie does have so many good moments
that I do think ultimately you'll be
easy for most people to overlook but the
stuff that doesn't work quite as well in
depth dives into a variety of cinematic
topics know this movie is absurd it's my
type of absurd mmm interviews with
amazing guests something in me said just
shut up and Miss Lansbury said oh I
couldn't as she sang the first couple of
lines cappella and the place went wild
and much much more yeah it wasn't until
I've watched you in bed at the hospital
[Music]
we'll be adding new episodes weekly and
we'll be uploading our backlog of
episodes that have been previously
published so subscribe today and we hope
you enjoy listening as much as we love
talk
you